Variety choice at,
at,
you know,
one of the things that we're growing are
basically dependent on what will grow
well in,
in our ecosystem again.
So,
uh,
you know,
we're basically getting seeds that
either are from the same latitude around
the world or from seeds that we know
have grown here in the past.
I mean,
we're,
right now we're growing a type of corn,
uh,
called,
eight row flint corn now,
eight row flint corn.
Uh,
we did an experiment,
some guy,
crazy guy from North Carolina who's
obsessed with saving seeds,
paid us a,
paid our farmer Jack $2,000 to plant it
was 75 of these,
these corn corn plants of eight row
flint corn.
He said,
now it was a,
it was the most popular corn,
uh,
among the native American Indians.
And they used to prize it for its
ability to dry and feed a feed the
tribes during the,
during the winter.
And so jack and I was very skeptical
that this would germinate at all.
Um,
and in fact,
we got 99 percent germination and we got
incredible corn now we harvested it.
And just like,
this is out of,
you know,
like if you write this into a novel,
you would think like,
this is just not to be believed,
but we harvest the next day,
the next day I'm reading this,
this,
this brochure from a very famous,
um,
uh,
marketplace and actually Michigan that
sells wholesale and retail around the
country.
And I opened up to like the middle of
the,
the pamphlet and,
and they say,
oh,
the most famous Italian placenta,
we now have it on sale oto feel a from
Italy and Oto feel a translate is eight
row flint corn.
So it's the Italians that recognized
from the Indians this incredible core
and that could make this unbelievable
polenta took it from us,
preserved it while we in the United
States have completely lost that except
really for the seeds that we had growing
that ended up Germany.
I mean there's,
there's a little.
He paid some other farmers to grow and
they didn't really germinate well,
but we are preserving what is our
natural heritage in our natural ecology.
I mean,
this is where I was going to ne was
what's corn country?
You know,
for the native Indians,
and so the Italians recognize this,
you know,
hundreds and hundreds of years ago and
have preserved it over these small
family farms.
Um,
so it's,
you know,
it's one of those things.
So,
so now we grind our own Polenta,
you know,
it's like back into the turn of the
century,
you know,
we're,
we're like a well Miller and we grind
our own plant.
Do we make this unbelievably flavorful?
Belie that people cannot taste it and
they like,
they've never tasted polenta and their
life,
you know,
when they have this stuff now,
now it's really great point that there's
no question I gave you a ball right now.
You would flip out.
It's so good because you're really
tasting things that have been hybridized
out of it.
Uh,
you know,
flavors and oils and the,
in the German,
all that stuff are incredible.
But also by the way,
it's more helpful.
That's another thing.
Our research is that,
that in that germ,
in that oils are a lot of micronutrients
that totally brought out over the course
of,
of generations.
But,
but I tell that story about this wacky
dude at Beta $2,000 and the native
Americans and autofill April flicker,
and the response in the dining room is
as if you've just given them,
you know,
the secret to life,
right?
Because they're tasting now all of a
sudden,
you know,
I mean they're tasting Italy and,
and tradition and all this stuff that,
and,
and the tradition of Italy is based
actually on America.
This is like all the things that just
like totally drank the koolaid right
away,
you know.
So it's great.
Polenta is no question,
but it's much better because I have that
story that we can relate to everybody
and that makes me look like a better
chef.
You know,
even in my best days,
I don't lack an ego.
I'm not having an ego like the rest of
the chefs,
but I,
the,
I cannot cook as well as those stories
can make people taste things they
otherwise wouldn't taste the seasoning.
That's just priceless.
So I like to get more of those stories
in self interest because it makes my
food taste.
Yeah.